so thank you for this opportunity i mean
this has just been a great meeting the
past two days we've seen so many great
talks and posters i'm very excited
and so um what's interesting though is
as i was preparing this talk
i realized that today is 25 years to the
day since i started my postdoc
and so i had just finished my phd work
under the direct direction of dr bruce
rowe at the university of oklahoma where
we were sequencing regions of human
chromosome 22 is part of the human
genome project and on april 1 1997
i began my postdoctoral study at the nih
under the direction of dr francis
collins now i can tell you if you've
never started a new job on april fool's
day it is quite the experience
and so as the new green postdoc i was
immediately the april fool and the easy
target of many practical jokes in my new
lab
but what i didn't realize at that point
was that this was the beginning of a
translational career built on genomics
and its application to human health and
so i was fortunate to not only
contribute sequencing data to the human
genome project but to also be in the
epicenter of human genomic research in
the u.s upon completion of the human
genome reference sequence in 2003 so at
that time i was infused with optimism
about what we could do to understand
human health and disease how we could
further understand what makes each of us
alike but also what makes each of us
different so how are we different in our
responses to environmental stimuli to
pharmaceutical drugs to chemotherapy
and since this day in 1997 i've studied
cancer and performed large-scale
transcriptomic analyses of several tumor
and cancer syndromes i've worked in the
drug development and pharmaceutical
industry and then now here we are 25
years later i'm translating what i've
learned in each of these varied research
environments to supporting patient
management in our cap accredited
clinical precision medicine laboratory